Space is a very old and dusty place.
And that’s because our solar system began
as a big dust cloud billions of years ago.
Gravity eventually pulled all these dust particles
together to create comets and planets.
But gravity didn’t clean everything up.
There’s still a lot of cosmic dust floating
out there, residing in the space between stars.
And, some of it is probably right next to
you.
Cosmic dust are specs of material, about 0.01
millimeters in size.
But good things come in small packages.
These microscopic bits are made up of carbon,
iron, oxygen, silicon, and magnesium.
Those elements sound familiar right?
They’re the raw materials that the planets
in our solar system are made of, and us humans.
There's so much of it swirling around, that
nearly 60 tons of the stuff fall on Earth
every single day.
But to enter the Earth’s atmosphere, the
little dusties use bubbles as parachutes,
preventing them from burning up upon entry.
We can find bits of cosmic dust everywhere,
on city rooftops, in Antarctica, and on the
cliffs of dover.
And these extraterrestrial particles can tell
us a lot about the history of our solar system.
So here on earth, you’re probably no more
than a few feet away from a piece of space.